[Music]
how would you go about fixing this
wobbly bridge
[Music]
how about changing this grid pattern to
make it symmetrical
when people solve problems typically
they
think well what can i add that will make
it better wait also left to right
i see there's a couple of green boxes i
need to change i could have got this is
not i should have taken
we tend not to ask ourselves what can we
take away from
it what can we subtract what can we
remove that might still make something
better
lydia klotz is an engineer who's
fascinated by the psychology
of design he started to notice
that people's first instinct is often to
add
one real epiphany was playing legos
actually with my son ezra who's about
two and a half at the time and we were
building a lego
bridge basically and so the two columns
on the bridge one was longer than the
other one
and so to make the bridge level i turned
around to
grab a block to add to the shorter
column
and by the time i had turned around ezra
had just removed a block from the longer
column
lydie realized that in many cases
removing an element
actually leads to better design one
example that we love
is the balance bikes the pedal-less
miniature bikes that allow two-year-olds
to ride
if you've seen a little two-year-old
going on these things i mean it just
makes you disappointed that you didn't
have it
when you were a kid but the breakthrough
was just taking away the pedals
it took decades for someone to think of
removing the pedals
rather than adding stabilizers
and yet through history people have
championed different kinds of minimalism
people are familiar with marie kondo
right tidying your home but
you know going back you think uh
leonardo da vinci his famous
definition of perfection is um when
there's nothing left to take away and
my personal favorite is wow sue which is
i'm paraphrasing here but to gain
knowledge add things every day to gain
wisdom
subtract things every day and what's
interesting about this is
all throughout history there have been
these reminders but the fact that we
need a reminder is
some of the best evidence that our
brains don't think of it
on their own lydia's been working with a
team of behavioral scientists
to try and figure out why our brains
default to adding
and what if anything can be done to
change this
so in our first study we showed people a
lego structure that looked like this
and the instructions were to improve the
structure so that it could hold a brick
above a small figurine most of the
participants
added bricks for support that is unless
the experimenters reminded people that
they could add
or remove bricks half of participants
were told that each piece that you add
costs 10 cents and the other half of
participants
were told that each piece that you add
costs 10 cents but removing
pieces is free so when we reminded
participants that removing pieces is
free
participants were much more likely to
remove pieces from the structure
than when we didn't remind them without
reminders
only 41 of people took away the extra
brick
but when queued 61 went with the cheaper
solution
could it be that taking things away just
doesn't occur to people
gabrielle wanted to know what other
factors affect this behavior
for example what if people tried the
task while distracted by something else
we gave them a 10 by 10 grid during the
task you'll be given a set of patterns
change each pattern so it's perfectly
symmetrical from left to right
and from top to bottom subtracting would
require fewer clicks
than adding and the instructions were to
use as few clicks as possible but there
was another task that participants were
asked to do
at the same time right press
f every time you see a five
[Laughter]
there's another five okay if there's
another five i've not even got a time to
start the task two
fives oh lots of fives um
finally i think i've got it okay done
what we find
is that when they are under what we call
cognitive load
so when they are distracted when their
attention is taken up by another task
that's when it tends not to occur to
people
that they could solve the task by
removing those extra squares
i could have got this is not i should
have taken
idea let me retreat
when people have more time or attention
or cognitive resources
they're more likely to find the more
efficient solution
but adding things was still the default
response across a range of examples and
conditions studied
so this is a novel heuristic heuristics
are
basically mental shortcuts that people
take when they process
any kind of information and so by
identifying
one way in which that information
processing
is biased that it's biased toward
additive
solutions and not thinking of
subtractive ones
i really think that we're we're on to
something kind of new here
gabrielle and the team think that this
previously unrecognized
bias in thinking could have big
implications when we overlook
subtraction
that's when we get things like
overburdened schedules
busy people increasing red tape and
institutions
and we're missing out on opportunities
right opportunities to make our lives
more fulfilling institutions more
effective
institutions more efficient and even to
make the planet better
more livable more green more sustainable